you
hi everyone is Gerry there's a basic
trap for white out of the Queens gambit
accepted that can easily catch an
opponent who grabs material and tries to
hang on to it here's how it works
d4 d5 c4 the Queens gambit it's accepted
and now III simply looking to recapture
and develop now before I get to the trap
itself let me just point out that if
you're concerned about making sure you
can recapture that material and you're
singing Bishop e6 you can be replying
Knight to a3 not to say that this is
best but just to quickly point out a way
that you can go ahead and regain that
material Knight 83 would do the trick
but showing the trap itself that comes
after blacks poor response b5 white now
follows up with a for the typical
undermining of a pawn structure and I
could see black going wrong in a couple
ways at this point with a6 or c6 a6 I
think is the easier variation to
calculate as being bad because after a
takes being you can't recapture because
you'd be losing the rook and so instead
I could see many players on the black
side playing c6 trying to defend b5 but
this too is bad because after a takes
being C takes being it's very easy to
overlook this silent move Queen to f3
and what to do about the threat on the
rook there's now not a successful
defense what's maybe best is to just
give up the night with the knight c6 and
after it's captured now black is in a
position to defend the rook but after
something like Queen a6 it doesn't
matter from this position white is
simply up a minor piece and winning
you